under the cover of the forest these men
work on t72 tanks some of which are
older than their parents
the location is secret it's close to the
front line because these tanks need to
be repaired and returned to the
battlefield quickly the methods are
simple and low-tech
21 year old bumper as he is known is a
mechanic and tank driver he's just come
back from Battle
it was like raining shells and mines on
us the field was full of craters and
mines and the commander of my unit died
when his tank burned with him in it the
work is arduous and difficult but
there's no other choice when they fixed
and upgraded the tanks make their way
back to their positions we have been
taken to where the tank is hidden now it
has to be really well hidden because
there's always drones up in the air
where Russians could spot the position
of the tank and then Target it this tank
crew are getting ready in case they
called out to fight
everything is simpler than this tank
than others
good
of course it's better to receive the
more modern Western tanks we could then
keep these in reserve it turns out we're
fighting t-72s against t-72s the Western
tanks are made to fight against
tank crews are in high demand and
essential to Ukraine's counter-offensive
500 days before have passed and I
haven't seen my family I'm not given any
leave there's no opportunity the two
sides are evenly matched and we barely
managed to beat them
When the Call Comes in they have to be
prepared to take positions
this part of eastern Ukraine has Russian
forces on three sides when firing they
have to be quick
shell lands just meters away they've
been spotted they managed to get away
undercover it's always a relief but they
know every Mission could be their last
Al Jazeera near the front line eastern
Ukraine